you do voices you do a lot of
impressions
uh i've noticed over the years i've been
doing this uh i've been on the air
in comedy for 22 years and i've never
met anybody
who did a conan impression which i think
i did conan on the show yeah
you do a conan impression i did it on
snl yeah i buy you a conan i do a really
good conan
i swear to god i've never heard anybody
do a conan
really so yeah and you're busy oh it's
so easy doing it
yeah it's easy uh conan's kind of like
you know you're like this and yeah and
you do this thing and then it's kind of
like
how you doing
that's it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
two twos
[Laughter]
ah conan o'brien
that's eerie that is like you yeah yeah
like how you eat where it's just like
now you eat slow i do not eat slowly
everything about that is common it puts
things whole and just
a pelican yeah that's me
that's how you eat right so i
every eat we hang out with you it's
always weird at restaurants yeah to
brief my wife
i have them bring me whole fish
and for mr o'brien
uh a documentary now let's have a
documentary now
we'll get back
you